when Andy Cohen was here yeah he said  that I saw this I don't know why that  was just my natural exuberance of life  what was it Andy's thing I said that I  was the drunkest at the Met Ball know  called in to my show and said who was  drunk at the Met Ball and I was like oh  there was a talk-show host and the only  ones that were there were a Stephen  Colbert yeah and the James Corden right  so it's one of those two right they  drank themselves silly yeah I'm gonna  guess who is it who is it  it was referring it was James Corden I  think people often think I'm drunk just  because I'm just having such a nice time  and the reason I was having such a nice  time is that my wife and I were away  together for the first time in like a  year and a half and we had a baby six  months ago we have three kids now and we  had never left them before and the  prospect of a lying in them I didn't  have to wake up the next day to like  10:00 a.m. right  and that was inconceivable to me